- [Mark] Lydia.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Lydia where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Santa Barbara.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- [Lydia] No,
just my mom.
- [Mark] Just your mom.
Where was dad?
- I don't know,
he took off.
- [Mark] You never knew?
- No.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- Hard.
- [Mark] What were the
hard parts about it?
- Being raised.
- [Mark] Were there were problems with,
with your mom or-
- Yeah, she's an alcoholic.
- [Mark] Oh your mom's alcoholic?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what kind of of stuff went on
when you were a kid?
- A lot of abuse,
a lot of abuse.
Name calling.
- [Mark] What kind,
what kind of abuse?
- Mentally, emotionally even physically.
- [Mark] From your mom?
- Yeah and my sisters,
yeah.
- [Mark] And your sisters too?
- Yeah.
My mom didn't me when I was a baby.
She had me with my dad
and my dad didn't want
anything to do with her so,
I'm the reject of the family.
- [Mark] Are you the youngest?
- No I'm the middle.
- [Mark] You're in the middle?
But what made you feel
like you weren't wanted?
- She told me.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] That would do it.
That would do it.
What age were you when you left home?
- 15.
- [Mark] 15.
How bad did the
abuse get?
I mean,
what kind of stuff,
what happened?
- You mean my family
or out here?
- [Mark] With your mom,
with your family.
- Well,
she tried taking my life like a few times.
You know?
She-
- [Mark] She tried to what?
- Take my life.
- [Mark] Take your life?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How would she do that?
- She put a knife to me one time
when I was a young teenager.
When I was baby,
she tried to drown me.
And when I was a young adult,
she threw me out her car.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] When you were a young adult what?
- She threw me out of the car.
She pushed me out of the car.
- [Mark] Pushed you out of a car?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Did she treat your,
you have sisters?
- No.
- [Mark] Or brothers?
- No, they're the pedestals.
They were high up there
and I was down here.
I was the ugly one.
- [Mark] Did she treat them the same way
she treated you?
- No.
Just you.
- [Mark] So when you left home at 15,
where'd you go?
- The streets.
I found family there.
I don't like it
but I felt I fit in.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Did you join a gang?
- No never.
- [Mark] No.
Just people on the street that
became your new family.
- Yeah
but most of the time
I was by myself,
I'm alone.
Being out here is hard.
I have a lot of testimonies,
you know?
3 years ago I was kidnapped
and I was tortured out here pretty bad.
- [Mark] What happened?
- They grabbed a hold of me.
It was two girls
and two guys.
They spread me apart
and they beat me.
They took my teeth out,
they burned me.
Hated my hair,
broke my ribs,
my face.
They took my soul.
Took my spirit,
you know?
I'm not racist
but I'm scared of black people.
I might be one of the harmless
people out here.
See I forgive them,
I forgive everybody.
But,
I'm just by myself you know?
I'm tryna get into housing,
trying to get myself together.
- [Mark] Are you using any drugs?
- Marijuana.
- [Mark] That's it?
- I smoke marijuana.
I used to do heroin
but I've been clean
10 years.
- [Mark] You've been clean
off heroin for 10 years?
- Yeah off the streets,
I quit cold turkey
on San Julian
at the Drop-in Center.
- [Mark] Is it how you got clean?
- Yeah.
Cold turkey
and I never went back to it again.
- [Mark] You're one of the fewest
that ever would say that.
- You know,
being out here 28 years,
by the grace of God
I still have my sanity you know?
And this place does seem to shock me,
you know?
It sickens me,
it saddens.
The way things are happening now.
With everything that's going around,
you know?
- [Mark] How many years
have you been in Skid Row?
- 28 years.
[Mark] 28 years?
- [Mark] Jesus.
And how old are you?
- I'm 52.
- [Mark] 52.
Did you have kids?
- I have two boys.
- [Mark] Did you raise them?
- Yeah somewhat.
Being out here,
I've heard things
I didn't want to hear.
I've see things
that I didn't even wanna see.
Things have happened to me
that I don't wish upon my worst enemy.
But I'm okay you know?
About a month ago,
I was hit by a car.
It was on purpose.
I got,
you know his information
so I'm getting me up out of here,
you know?
I don't wanna ask for to much,
I don't wanna ask for too little.
Just what's fair,
you know?
See my family again,
- [Mark] Do you still talk to your kids?
- They're mad at me right now.
They're,
they're kind of stern hard,
tough love.
But I do keep in contact-
- [Mark] But they're mad at you
for what reason now?
If you're clean off heroin.
- Because I'm out here.
But they don't open the door to me,
to me either
You know?
I don't wanna bother them.
It's just hard out here,
you know?
And it's even more dangerous now.
Everybody's dying out here.
- [Mark] You've been here 28 years,
What kind stuff have you seen?
What have you seen?
- Rapes.
Brutal murders.
Men beating up on women.
Men raping men.
Animals being abused.
People literally shitting
and sleeping on crap.
(car engine)
People on spice.
That really kicks my butt.
'cause I've had 4 friends
die on spice already.
- [Mark] It's an awful drug.
So why did you still live here
if you're not doing heroin?
- Because I don't feel I fit into society.
Society is hard.
People are cruel.
You know,
I should be used to the name calling
but I'm not.
It still hurts,
you know?
People look at me
like I'm a monster.
And here they don't do that.
- [Mark] Do you think the way
that you were raised,
the way your mom treated you is,
has a part to play in that?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Your self-perception is-
- My self esteem-
- [Mark] Yes,
it's just so low that you,
you think this is where you belong.
- Yeah.
Thank you.
- [Mark] What are you doing for money now?
- I recycle.
I recycle cans.
It's never much.
I'll,
I'll hook somebody's tan up for them.
You know I'll hook it up for them
and they'll pay me or whatever,
a couple dollars.
- [Mark] In the past,
have you done other things for money?
- No,
I don't steal,
I don't prostitute,
I don't take from people,
I don't take things
that don't belong to me.
I don't like stealers you know.
I'd been mistaken for somebody,
for somebody else
and they tried to assassinate me.
They wanted to kill me.
Because I was thought
I was like somebody else.
A few times.
And when the truth finally came out,
I didn't even get an apology.
People take for me.
Because they can.
It's hard you know?
People think it's just that easy,
it's easy to be homeless,
it's not.
(indistinct)
you know my laundry,
my bedding
her hygiene,
my radio,
my batteries,
my lights.
My pair of shoes.
But I'm all right you know,
God takes care of me.
I'm all right.
(indistinct)
- [Lydia] I want to puppy.
I want a puppy so bad it hurts.
You know I see all these animals
out here being abused.
For fighting or,
it's so wrong you know.
I was talking to a couple people
for abusing their animals.
If an animal could talk imagine,
you know?
I've been bullied,
I had a stalker on me.
About 3 or 4 months ago,
I was raped.
I told the police
and they didn't do nothing.
They said I probably asked for it.
I've tried to get my house,
I've been trying for 2 years.
(car engine)
Except they always tell
me something's wrong.
I'm tired of relationship,
you can't have a relationship out here.
But I'm lonely too.
I'm just tired.
I'm tired of havin' to go to sleep scared.
Sleeping with my shoes on.
So I can escape and run.
People turn on you in a heartbeat.
I have no friends out here.
People know that I'm by myself
so what do they do?
They take advantage of me.
But they also give a sweater
or a pair of,
you know a bar of soap.
To trust someone is hard.
- [Mark] Looking back at your life.
What do you,
what do you wish had played out
differently that might've
changed your path?
- Peace of mind.
Just to live comfortably
and live in peace
and have peace.
Just to be peaceful.
To have no stress or worries.
Just peace.
- [Mark] Do you feel like your childhood
was so traumatic that it just kind of
set you back
and kept you that way?
And now you're here?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You don't feel like you're
capable of getting out?
- I'm trying.
But something always sets me back.
Like I said I was,
I was hit by the car.
Then a few weeks after that,
I fell
and I had an accident on my bike.
I messed up my ribs.
They told me to just relaxing.
And the medic was telling me to relax.
But I gotta move.
No one's been there for me.
If I don't get up
and recycle,
I don't eat.
I buy my things
just cause people still
steal my things
It's just not fair,
you know.
I don't mess with people.
I don't take from them.
- [Mark] Do you think you'll stay here
the rest of your life?
- God I hope not.
I prayer to God,
I hope I don't.
- [Mark] But you've been down here
for almost 3 decades.
- I know.
I got sick out here.
People have been,
I lot of people dying out here you know,
overdosing or
beating or killing or something.
It's scary.
When I got hit by that car,
and I was laying
in the street,
by myself,
I was scared.
The only thing I wanted
was my mom.
- [Mark] Is your mom's still around?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you talk to her?
- No.
She's real negative.
She'll just throw 'em worse at me,
you know?
She'll just throw at me more shit
not making me feel better.
- [Mark] So you don't talk to your mom,
you don't talk to your kids?
- No I mean I talk to my sister
and my sisters tell the boys
"hi"
you know,
and that I love 'em
and I miss 'em.
Other than that,
no I don't talk to them.
They don't want to talk to me.
They don't understand why I ran away.
They don't understand why I stay away.
But then again
I don't expect them to either,
you know?
I don't really expect their forgiveness,
Just don't stop loving me.
I don't wanna give 'em hope.
I'm suicidal.
About,
5 months ago
I tried hanging myself.
Right there
in front of everybody.
- [Mark] What's that?
- It was at night,
down San Ped.
People just walked by.
Cars just drove by.
Some of 'em just sat there
and laughed.
I may become a Jane Doe
if I stay out here.
And I not,
I don't want that to happen to me.
I know I'm somebody.
God don't make junk,
right?
A guy talks to me nicely,
right away I think
he wants something.
Or I get really attached to them.
To what?
For what?
To start beating up again.
Stealing from me?
Are people talk behind my back?
You know?
I heard officers call me names.
And my mama thinks I not anyone
I'm not even a stranger.
And the people that kidnapped me
are still out there.
And they bully me.
They intimidate me now.
I don't know what to do.
- [Mark] What you,
what do you think is stopping you
from just getting out of Skid Row?
Changing your life,
getting a job, getting a-
- My appearance.
- [Mark] Your what?
- [Mark] What's wrong
with your appearance?
- Look at me.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- Look at my skin.
- [Mark] You're beautiful,
what's it matter?
- Just the other day
someone called me Pizza Face.
I was told I was ugly.
- [Mark] Do you think that maybe
your self-perception might be
the biggest problems you have?
- My what?
- [Mark] Your self-perception
might be the biggest problem
that you have?
- What's perception mean?
- [Mark] The way you see yourself.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Because I look at you.
I see you're,
You're beautiful.
I see nothing wrong with you.
- You're just being nice.
I had my ex-boyfriend
tell me I was ugly.
My boyfriend.
And he's disabled.
I was taking care of him
for two years.
He's confined in a wheelchair.
For what?
I didn't even get a
thank you.
He took advantage of me.
He'd throw his diapers at me
and he hit me to be mean.
Disrespect me.
Call me names.
He took advantage of me.
But I felt important,
you know?
I don't wanna be here anymore.
I never did.
But the drugs got a hold of me,
you know?
(car engine)
When I first came out here,
I was working crack.
24 years old.
I didn't know what the hell it was.
But my sister got me involved with it.
"Taste it you'll like it"
27 years later,
look at me now.
(indistinct)
I wanna see if
I can go onto Ellen DeGeneres.
They say she knows somebody
who'll give me a laser.
A laser treatment for my face.
I wanna be beautiful.
I wanna have pretty skin,
you know?
And I wanna wake up every morning
and put makeup on my face
but be scared if
what if I can't.
People are mean,
- [Mark] All right Lydia.
Thank you so much for talking to me.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck with everything.
- Thank you Mark.